if you concentrate and focus in your
life on what you don't have you will
never have enough if you have a healthy
lunch and you know you're properly
fueled and then you also have positive
people in your life
everyone's motivated by the end of the
day you're gonna feel good when you talk
to people who have found the work they
were born to do
they are so excited about it you can
tell that they have found something that
is really unique and really special
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out under the world now I started to
believe life series too once a week
tackle different topics that are outside
the realm of just starting a business so
to help you live your best believe life
today we're gonna learn seven science
pact habits to help you live happier and
be more successful enjoy
[Music]
habit number one is Journal with Oprah
Winfrey as I grown older I've learned to
appreciate living in the moment
and I ask that you do - I've asked I'm
asking this graduating class those of
you here I've asked all of my viewers in
America and across the world to do this
one thing keep a grateful Journal every
night list five things that happened
this day in days to come that you are
grateful for what it will begin to do is
to change your perspective of your day
and your life I believe that if you can
learn to focus on what you have you will
always see that the universe is abundant
and you will have more if you
concentrate and focus in your life on
what you don't have you will never have
enough be grateful keep a journal habit
number two is get your email under
control with Tim Ferriss how do I deal
with email overload there are a few
tools that very much help for this so
the first that I would mention is a tool
called boomerang what boomerang allows
you to do is schedule automatic
follow-ups so you don't have to remember
to check if someone has replied for
instance and you can set parameters for
that you can also set a time a future
date and time when your email will be
set this is extremely extremely helpful
the next tool is email game it seems
very silly in some respects because it's
gamified but you'll generally knock out
your email probably 40 50 % faster and
the reason for that is it doesn't allow
you to look at your inbox it takes you
sequentially through every email you
can't just click on it go I don't want
to deal with that right now mark is on
read you can't do that the next is to
routinely go through your inbox star
things that are from close family
important contacts who manage your life
and say an accountant or whatever it
might be and then archive all the rest
with the assumption that if it's
important it's going to come to you a
second time
in the last recommendation I would say
is that you should not treat email like
a chat tool and whenever possible you
should use an augmenting tool to handle
that function my team and I use slack
for a lot of these conversations I would
additionally say that just emptying your
inbox does not mean you've accomplished
anything habit number three is travel
with the vagabrothers well there's only
so much you can learn from books travel
teaches from experience and experience
is the best teacher of all what better
way to learn about history and hiking up
Machu Picchu exploring angkor wat at
dawn or wandering ancient roman ruins
that's what makes travel so valuable
because it opens your mind and broadens
your perspectives and as cliche as it
sounds
Travel can help you find yourself
sometimes we don't know who we are and
what we want to do can we step away from
family and friends and tune into your
inner voice after college I traveled
through Southeast Asia gone to blogging
and storytelling which eventually led me
to team up with my brother to found this
channel
that's because travel gives you the
space to just be you in a way that you
could never do back home how about
number four is read with Warren Buffett
I should mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at Columbia I
wish I spent probably more time than any
other soon
I lived there practically but then I
pulled the book out there have to be
who's an American that told me something
about my professor Benjamin Ram and then
I looked up and I went to the library
and I said I want to learn more about
this because I learned this over here
that changed my whole life
you know we owned I go now because of
that library and directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that now it's the chance I read about
one-fifth the pace the bill does but I
still spend five or six hours a day
reading I mean it just you can learn so
much I love biography just
to be able to live the lives of these
people have been extorted didn't see
them so extraordinary in the lessons and
the you know the discouragements they
face just everything about it so I did
you can't get enough of reading that
done how about number five is exercise
with Joe Rogan and jockle willing
there's a lot of people that are eating
food and then by the end of the day your
body's in a crisis yeah yeah body's just
processing all this [ __ ] yeah and
people asked me that too they go you
know how much you sleep first of all I
get asked all the time so I go to bed
around 11:00 I woke up wake up around
4:30 ABS that's five and a half hours
sometimes I sleep more than that
sometimes I go to bed at 10:00 10:30
11:00 sometimes I stay up later but when
the person says to me ah you know I
can't do that I feel horrible how can I
feel better and my first question is
like what are you eating
what are you eating because if you're
eating Cheetos and chocolate chip
cookies for lunch there's no way you're
gonna feel good not cure if you slept 12
hours a night before yeah that's a it's
a giant factor and if you're eating a
big like [ __ ] lunch filled with
nonsense like your body's got to process
all that stuff and so the end of the day
yeah you're gonna lose your willpower
so like when five o'clock six o'clock
rolls around you're gonna be tired but
if you have a healthy lunch and you know
you're properly fueled and then you also
have positive people in your life
everyone is motivated by the end of the
day you're gonna feel good like say if
you're going if you're doing jiu-jitsu
with a bunch of other people that are
doing jiu-jitsu everybody's enjoying it
you're looking forward to that 6:30
class everybody's fired up you get out
of work you're pumped man you what you
doing it when you get out of work you're
fueling up with water you're trying to
get some electrolytes in you because you
know you're gonna get out there on the
mats you're gonna sweat it out yeah and
the thing you got to do too is when you
get done with work and it was a grind it
you didn't get you get crappy food and
whatever happened happened and you got
yelled at by your boss or whatever and
the real easy decision is to be like I'm
not gonna go train tonight those the
night you gotta train because that is
gonna kick you back on the track real
quick when you get in there and you see
your boys and they're they're getting
ready to tear you up on the mats and
that's gonna get you on track as opposed
to going home and watching TV which
isn't gonna do anything for you yeah and
if there's not anything whatever the
thing is just go and do it just force
yourself to do it and if you feel like
because you ate lunch then your lunch
was you know filled with [ __ ] well
then hey dummy don't eat you lunch
tomorrow tomorrow try a nice salad yeah
salad with some salmon and see how you
feel then hey I feel way better today at
6 o'clock duh yeah now your
decision-making will be better like they
people don't understand how significant
it is like all these little decisions
they those are like that that's the path
for the rest of your existence on earth
and if you decide to go to Cheetos
chocolate chip cookie route you're just
making a path you're carving your path
through broken rocks and glass and it's
not the way to go there's no doubt that
the the life change decision isn't one
big decision that you're making these
little tiny decisions it's you know
having a salad instead of Cheetos that's
that's that's what it is on a daily
basis and if you think about that and
then you just make the right decision on
those little things that's where that's
where the change in Jesus habit number
six is think about the lifestyle that
you want with Chris Guillebeau
I think a lot of people when I talk to
people about this book they were worried
about mistakes they had made and they
were worried about like you know I had
this opportunity and I let it go or I
should have done this I ended up doing
something different I really learned
that you can recover from most mistakes
like most of us have made mistakes we've
done different things and and that's
that's normal so there are a lot of
different paths I don't think there's
just necessarily one path you know for
everyone you know there's this whole
like claim about you know the road not
taken' or the road less traveled and I
took this one it made all the difference
but we don't really know the other story
right we don't know what happened like
what if you'd actually gone back and
taken the other one maybe it would have
been great too maybe it would have been
better so I do think there's more than
one path but I also think when you talk
to people who have found the work they
were born to do they are so excited
about it you can tell that they have
found something that is really unique
and really special so even though
there's more than one path I think it's
important to kind of work toward
whatever this special thing has worked
toward this this combination of factors
to where like we're really happy and we
have all the money that we need and
we're doing something that we're really
good at I think I think that's the goal
right so it's not like this one elusive
thing but if you look at really
successful people if you look at Beyonce
like Beyonce probably could have done a
bunch of different things but isn't it
so good that she's doing you know what
she's doing or anyone that you admire
you kind
look at them and you're like they have
really found their thing habit number
seven is spend time with nature with
Robin Sharma one of my favorite
protocols is the daily nature walk I
love walking in the woods I often listen
to audiobooks in the woods
I call it walk reading while walking
reading while walking so I go to this
place it's sort of my creative forest
there's not a lot of people in there and
I walk for one hour I breathe in the air
I look at the lush scenery I listen to a
different audiobook I it's almost like a
walking meditation as well sometimes I
don't listen to an audio book and I just
walk and I touched the earth it's almost
like I'm thanking the earth connecting
with the soil yes I'm wearing shoes I
don't want to get too esoteric here but
there's a lot of really good research
saying if you want to boost your immune
system you want to boost your happiness
you want to release serotonin dopamine
you want to release the fear hormone
called cortisol walk in nature and so
when I walk I connect with nature
now I've got a very special bonus clip
from Satguru that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that commitment
of the day I want to know which of these
seven habits resonated the most with you
and what are you going to commit to
today to now applying one of these
habits to your life leave it down the
comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
if you can find
place where there are no sounds of
machines and your cell phone will not
think think quietly if you can listen to
the sound of the trace the breeze the
water just the natural sounds if you pay
enough attention tremendous things will
happen many times have been in the South
Indian you know they're kind of tropical
rainforest the longest have been there
through the jungle for about 23 days
alone no any kind of support no
cellphone for sure those days then not
even a torchlight
and fourth day I ran out of the food
that I was carrying so I lived off the
forest by about eight today I lost my
jacket and one half of my shirt because
I was chased by some animals and by him
that whole thing I had half a shirt and
pants and I walked through ice this is
elephant country tiger country iso
tigers panthers elephants all kinds of
the wild buffalo various kinds of
animals very close quarters but
at the end of it when you look back what
is the biggest impact on you
it's the insects it's in the nights the
orchestra that goes on in the rainforest
[Music]
it's unbelievable and the timing every
day night 2:15 means one group will stop
another group will start really the
sense of time every day exactly by the
second one group will start and a group
will start you don't know what they're
talking about they're definitely talking
something that you don't know for sure
they're not just making dumb noises so
if you just sit there and listen and
listen and listen and listen
Roli you start noticing there is a
pattern and an organization to this
which is far bigger than any human
symphonies that you can achieve far more
complex and far more intense I think
it's really important for every human
being
particularly if you have children
vacation need not be Disneyland I'm not
against it but one trip is enough all
silly stuff which excites you
vacation should be into nature if you
can take and children walk in a jungle
not in a resort just live in a mountain
expose them to nature I will tell you
you will bring up your children not only
physically healthy mentally healthy far
more sensible and accepting and
wonderful kind of human beings if they
know how to because once you go into
nature whose son you are whose daughter
you are what are you in the city doesn't
matter ok it's very important that
everybody experiences that otherwise you
start creating your own illusions as to
who you are and you start believing it
for sure
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or absolutely I'm faster
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten most success I
have a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details